one thing I did hear Jaco says it was
just crazy but it kind of makes sense
where he goes anytime you feel like you
have a diet urge that you can't control
it'll just fast for 24 hours get back in
control dude dudes like that who are
already like built like a truck and and
then they're like just fast for 24 a
whole day
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
interesting episode of the careful boys
where we are currently off the Record
and today's prompt is going to be maybe
dangerous but I believe in our
friendships with each other that we're
going to be able to do this one well
okay so do it I got it today the prompt
is let us all give each other
constructive criticism oh no but like
about what anything
just I think you have too much sex
Anthony how about that that's true I
think you deflect and go right to jokes
when we try to talk about something
serious maybe you gotta start first you
start first so we know what the what the
tone is
maybe start first we know what the hell
with the tone who's gonna wear those no
no
we buy exam
give me some constructive criticism can
I can I get a donut
okay you want chocolate that's gonna be
my criticism I don't want to start with
John I don't want to get fired
constructive criticism what is that
there's only two left I'm an employee
asking you for constructive criticism of
his performance of my performance go
like in the lands of JK sure okay let's
do that oh in the lens of JK or in life
if you want to be a little demoralized
we'll do we'll do first round JK second
round I like that I like that
how you can improve Anthony is not
[__] have such a wild ass schedule
please yeah because all of us locked in
our dates
and I get it you got other things
okay it's so [__] cool but at the
same time it makes Parts world and job
horrible not for me I don't care but I
see the group text and I'm just like oh
Bart I feel bad for you this would help
if I heard this from Bart okay
so I just feel bad for Bart then it's
everything Joe said hi constructive
criticism I would like it so when you
get gigs for kendras it makes me happy
as a friend but for JK I'm my mother
[__] [__] because it's like you got
all these [__] Disneyland blackout
dates for [__]
I was trying to book [__] and it's hard
yeah it's complicated you need like a
food no I mean that I think that's
criticism I think the constructive part
is supposed to come now like what can he
do about that yeah because sorry in
advance because June's gonna be fun but
I want you to keep having gigs because I
know it's good for you and you're
getting paid also makes me happy if we
can't cover the rest of your costs I get
it too that's why I I don't I I don't
say anything
do you have a constructive response is
that constructive well the constructive
part is that like we're supposed to be
like
but we have a solution for you which we
don't I just want to criticize you
because I don't know what else to say
this type of company that's okay though
that's okay I'd rather hear it because I
think that that's oh but here's the
thing though I feel like it's it's
pointless sometimes because we already
know the answer we already know the
outcome and it's like also if I can't do
my part and make your life better for
making my life better with the
scheduling then why open my mouth about
it you know what I mean that's why I
don't like I don't feel the reason to
criticize unless I can remedy it that's
why I was looking for the constructive
part we don't have one because you're
good so if I had a gripe with you that's
the only gripe exactly yeah your overall
performance is solid so why why bring up
weird [__]
[Laughter]
hey you're [__] dope but let me just
find something to nitpick dude like
you're on time more than everybody else
right oh that's not what you do we shoot
nitpicks that's what this is
constructive nitpicks yeah
but not just me because you're forcing
our [__] hand here it's a prompt guys
it's a good prompt that's what I'm
saying maybe you could lead and I can go
oh that's what he's trying to do I don't
know he gave one to me or I don't know
what's yours he said he said uh I
deflect and I make jokes but what's the
constructive part where's the
constructive part that's my story arc
right now what's the construct oh I'm
gonna have a crap but listen
that's the constructive part no no we're
not doing construction anymore
just being petty we should be Petty
nitpicking and Petty yeah I like that
because that's better that's less
pressure yeah because there's nothing
wrong with the deflections because
people like it
I got one for Nick hey I thought we were
doing Anthony hey don't leave so fast
when we're done huh hey yeah I like you
[__] what can I say something
can I can I say something you know like
I think only me and Bart know because
Bart has a kid and now like as a proud
father of Two Brothers
hold on only this table knows what it's
like to like raise you know fatherhood
this is Nick when we wrapped on a JK day
right so it's like this it's like this
okay guys that's a wrap
Deborah
he's gone oh oh oh and and best of all
he he comes late and he always leaves
early what the [__] dude
can I say something you just leave so
quickly can I say something everybody
says this about me at the other gym too
oh yeah so if you're always leaving
places early where are you hanging out
at because because as you know as only
you know Bart I gotta go home and I
gotta you know I gotta raise these
puppies
on the phone right now
every tips has been making this joke of
since I've been working so much he's
like well it's just crazy that I'm a
single mom like she always says that it
says take care of two buck so she
probably shares the same thing well Dana
Latino see if she has it any better
that's what I tell her yeah
let's do it again I want that one
I did a Latino we will take it from the
top so we're gonna do a script doctor's
gonna come in I will say that everybody
just wants to hang out with you Nick so
like I want to hang out soon dude
you purposely when I'm in Pasadena you
purposely don't read my text till I'm in
another city
this is why I gotta pay for friends it's
because if if I could pay for this guy
to stay longer so he doesn't have to
have a second gig he would be chilling
that's true but what gig do you have
after JK like what's going on at 8pm 8pm
his puppy live stream I gotta yeah I
thought you do Jiu Jitsu yeah sometimes
he has to teach a jiu jitsu class uh I
gotta go home so I can spend quality
time with my wife because I'm gone all
day
I get that I get that oh yeah we shoot
on the weekend you know that makes sense
it makes sense but I mean a lot of
people in this room got wives you know
what I mean so it's like either all of
us are [__] or you gotta be okay
being an [__] once in a while too
yeah
people got wives and lives I think
recently well not just recently it's
just you decided to actually be a good
husband yeah kind of I looked in the
mirror I looked in the mirror and I was
like I'm kind of a piece of [__] no but
I I think that being uh as lame as it
sounds like being more present and being
more like around you know it would be
really buddy is if he takes this
criticism and then at the end of today
he just like hangs around and we're just
like all right later Nick
well you know what's even
It's the funniest part what about Monday
through Thursday you know kick it with
your wife you have to hang out you gotta
leave Friday and Saturday what the [__]
uh sometimes but like I get home late
Sunday so okay look my my work day
typically
when I'm teaching Jiu Jitsu at night I
start at like
I start sometimes 6 a.m 7 A.M I don't
get back until nine o'clock 9 30
sometimes Monday through Thursday yeah
oh okay yeah so that's when it's a
little tough and then on days we have JK
I see clients on Sunday mornings to the
whole like after like mid-afternoon yeah
and then it's like time to hang with the
fam and all that [__] if we if we
paid you more if we paid you more drop
clients so you could hang with us longer
uh I don't know see you watch
we should constructively criticize
ourselves and maybe just do a better job
of pre-communicating and planning when
we want to officially do something so
Nicki I agree hey you tried this Friday
we both tried we did try can I say
something please I knew I couldn't hang
out so I didn't text back we know you
didn't text back we assumed you couldn't
hang out even if it was pre-planned we
went to uh Joe's uh birthday dinner
yeah you came back from from rehearsal
that was really cool I did it for the
for the points and that was so fun and
remember what we said at dinner I was
like we gotta do this more
we did say that and of course Joe's
birthday was was when I wasn't here
[__] bummer but let's hang them well
today's Cinco de Mayo we're not hanging
tonight are we but me and this guy tried
yeah
multiple times for two weeks let's just
hang out with them without Bart we can
hang out tonight
he's leaving yeah I gotta get my wallet
I left my wallet at my friend's house
really so after this I gotta rush over
there it's fine we'll go watch the
Lakers what the junior high
I lost my velcro wallet at my friend's
house and fell in the cushions
do you guys have that thing isn't it
okay I'm wondering if it's a creative
person thing or a guy to constantly
[__] lose [__] bro that's why I got
this baby I got that too and it's that
fatty pack is at my friend's house the
whole family pack yes
I think it's a system why did you take
it off you got if you got the one two
three yeah always doing one two three
you're never but if you don't follow
systems dude I'm kind of OCD about it
I'll be at the airport I'll do one two
three like [__] for the whole time
there dude I look like freaking pie
Delta gamma all day yeah but how many of
you guys still do the one two three and
you still lose wallet keys everyone here
does I mean I've never lost my wallet
one kilo with this guy this guy right
here I haven't lost a thing dude you can
toggle stoves with that thing yeah it's
decreased it's decreased my frequency of
losing things because that's probably
the first time I lost my wallet in years
this is why women have purchases I get
it I lost my wallet because one day me
and Nikki went to this beach thing
that's why our community and we came
home and I just didn't know that I put
my wallet in my other shorts and like
they went through the laundry and I
found it but like I went and got a new
driver's license I was [__] pissed at
myself and I was [__] and then I do
laundry and I there's my wallet in the
middle of it oh oh that's a rough one
you're too productive that's what you
get for being too productive yeah you
got anyone else have anything for Nick
for constructive uh dude we spent five I
think we've been hitting pretty hard
lately yeah let's move on to somebody
else
what other Nick things are there hey if
we built like a like put some mats on
the ground back here would you do your
client stuff here so we can hang out
with them while he's [__] yeah I
haven't put a little Bowflex back there
yeah you guys are always welcome to come
hang at the gym it's too fine I highly
doubt we're welcome to hang out I bet
you are I bet you will go there and for
some reason you gotta bounce still
from a constructive criticism point I
will say a while ago you said you want
to like work on promoting yourself
better and uh since then I feel like you
haven't done any of that
but you guys could be clients now he
can't afford to do that
excuse me clients
I thought that was the way to you know
build the business but it's like yeah I
don't know I just you spread pretty
freaking Thin Man huh a little bit
hashtag razor rate I mean yeah I will
the [__] is that me I don't even know
what we're just so focused on this you
did something number one no yeah I I
feel like I feel like in a lot of ways
this is kind of promoting
just being on JK but even that goal I
just was like right after I said it I
was like oh
that's so funny about being honest hey
fair enough why do you hate helping
people what do you mean that's his job
because I think promoting yourself is
like look dude I could help you become
healthier look at what I did for David
he's always been fat until he met me
that's a really great uh Yelp review you
know I think you know David did most of
the heavy lifting but like for the most
part
yeah because he was pretty heavy that's
why you're not good at selling yourself
you should be sitting here taking the
[__] credit for this
you changed this man you know what Steve
I don't like that you wear white all the
time that's my construction there's a
deflecting finger yeah see hey if I got
you as a trainer if I hired you as a
personal trainer what could you improve
about me physically oh that's
constructive criticism better uh beard
easily better beard that's what you do I
would do that too better beard but make
it better just better I connect the top
half to the bottom half like if like if
I was like Hey Fitness wise like how can
I be more healthy like what would you
suggest not that I'm trying to make you
work for free right now if I honestly
you're probably just like well depends
on what you what you want to do what do
you what does Ryan want in your life
like what do you want to get better at I
don't know from from your from your
point of view what where can I where can
I uh get an A plus and this is where I
deflect again I go well it's not really
up to me it's up it's up to God yeah
yeah it's up to God I pull up my Bible
like this how do you have so many
clients
all right how about this give an honest
free consultation nutritionist approach
to Steve's health habits let's go oh go
for it dude I think this is total boring
stuff but no this is a good contest
but usually it starts with like but
honestly everything goes back to
whatever your goal is oh no look at me
in the eyes can I say something people
goes hey I need help with my caffeine
addiction not golf what do you do then
I'd ask what's your caffeine consumption
uh a lot a day a lot and then I have to
I'd have to quantify it like okay what
is a lot like how many like how many
milligrams is unhealthy
I do about four times that so you do 4
000 milligrams a day
I honestly actually don't
um do these anymore unless I'm on JK
yeah same I actually finally got off of
uh monsters so at home we don't drink at
all no in the morning I don't what did
you so maybe we should just have less of
them here that used to be my morning
routine too I would have a monster every
every single day and now I know one or a
couple I would have one in the morning
yeah every day you drink tons of
caffeine don't you all right me too me
too oh I drink a ton too hey okay here's
a real question like how do I how would
you suggest like I'm trying to get rid
of more like belly fat yeah what's a
good way to do that probably gonna go on
a diet probably gotta stop bringing
those Mochi Donuts to the [__] bomb
you probably gotta start lifting weights
and you probably gotta go on a little
bit of a diet start lifting weights yeah
okay and you probably gotta fix that
[__] beer dude how much how much he
makes it so simple how much do I owe you
for that ten thousand dollars please
Cheney with Nick is so simple you just
show up and he does all the work for you
when I was training with Nick he would
just be like all right do pull-ups all
right what's the best what's the best
like but that's the thing though a lot
of people that I've especially recently
that come and see me they think there's
a [__] secret right like they think
uh there's gotta be something like what
the secret is is self-awareness honestly
and I think a lot of it is just me
asking questions to people that they've
never answered out loud and they don't
even know and they go oh
yeah you know what the reason why I
can't sleep every night is because I'm
having a coffee at [__] 5 p.m yeah
maybe I'll push that to 2 p.m and then
the next day they're like hey I had a
great night of sleep last night hello
you're telling me that 300 milligram
coffee that you drink at 5 PM is helping
you I stay awake so it's like you sound
like Tim Robbins so much I didn't
[__] do it nah but that's just how it
goes yeah that's that's there's no
secret to the song but sometimes I think
people are underwhelmed when they hire
me sometimes this is bad underwhelmed
when they they ask like hey what do I
need to do and I tell them and I try to
make and that's part of what I try to do
is make it as simple as possible and
then they don't like that
they can't they don't they don't believe
it can't possibly that yeah exactly and
then and then sometimes that does shoot
me in the foot but then again it's like
then we aren't supposed to work together
right yeah that's how it comes out
because they want like a secret yeah and
then it goes all right well this ain't
really working out and a lot of it is
like show me you could do this for a
week and then we'll move on to the next
step that's cool but
once again sometimes bad for business
but I think from there it creates the
client base that I want a lot of the
best diets are like people go that's
stupid yeah yeah kinda because I used to
do it when I first started like doing
all this [__] yeah I thought there was a
secret and even you could take down
anything like oh how do I get a six
figure or seven figure business and it's
like simple question it is pretty simple
right yeah it's [__] serious it's so
much discipline and some people don't
even know the answers to that yeah so
it's like until you are recording that
and tracking that then you can't have a
metric of how you get better from there
that's true yeah but what if they want
to do it real fast you said what what if
they want to do a really really fast
cardano baby
to the Moon Yeah down to seven percent
in six months well I'm killing you guys
I'm killing you guys
80 up to your [__] I'm killing you
guys talk about it have you because when
when people go down the rabbit hole not
even the rabbit hole when they finally
get the motivation they want to jump on
that emotional rush and then they open
up that rabbit hole of this whole thing
that they've never done before and then
they just want to do everything so fast
and they feel so good yeah I think
that's that's probably like how they
approach everything like from finances
to Fitness to everything and most of the
time it's just not sustainable you can
only do that for like a month and maybe
even some change there's a riding on
motivation so instead of like completely
changing their lifestyle I think that's
for everything yeah
getting people to slow down you know
but when did you get this answer do you
go but but how long does it take for me
to lose my belly fat because I you know
I got a wedding to do and like I just
gotta get in the suit
I just be like don't eat for 30 days you
should have thought about that Daddy
that's what you say 30 days
[Laughter]
one thing I did hear Jocko sales I was
just [__] crazy but it kind of makes
sense where he goes anytime you feel
like you have a diet urge that you can't
control it'll just fast for 24 hours get
back in control oh I was like oh [__]
that's true if you don't if you don't
eat for one day you're not gonna die
yeah yeah so you're like oh [__] I want
McDonald's like nope just fast 24 hours
you have that thought don't eat for all
dude dudes like Dad who are already like
built like a truck and then and then
they're like just fast for 24 a whole
day that's a cake you [__] idiot yeah
cause you asked if you tell that to can
he's gonna die it's like it's like hot
women going just be attractive can I
tell you a dream that I had about Jocko
Little Nick that scared the shot at me a
couple a dream oh cool and it was I
don't usually don't dream and this was
very Vivid I had a dream I was hanging
out with Jocko will Nick or something at
his house and it seemed like we're in
Maine or something it was a very
beautiful home and he had a beachfront
property and show me around and then we
start hanging out at his like on his
couch and in this dream that was like
kind of lucid he started to like make up
pass at me and was like trying to make
sexual what the [__] yeah he was trying
to make out with me and I was like Yo
dude stop and I kept pushing him away
and then like
I got him to eventually stop and then I
woke up in like cold sweat you almost
got me tuned by Jocko what do you think
that means constructive you're hard can
I give you some construction criticism I
think you're gay
but the whole time I was like yo bro I
was like stop I was like please stop
he's good it sounds like it's like that
iced tea Cliff who goes I got news for
you you're gay I have relationships with
women but I have sex with men that means
you're gay straight guys don't have gay
dreams that means you're gay
but I successfully offended them off
waking up in cold sweat that means your
closet that means you want it dude
that's like when you were fighting my
Legend as being again maybe try it and
see if you still sweat yeah give me the
shirt dude no it's mine
that's like when Nikki's having a dream
about Eminem and she's like we almost
[__] and then I woke up and then she's
pissed that they didn't [__] yeah you're
like that
I wasn't pissed it was more of like me
being like what I was honestly worried I
was worried like why did I have this
dream and it felt it felt so real and
like it was it was great taco in Maine
that's what I'm saying like what is this
why are you guys gonna Chill on the
couch what does that mean
on the couch in my life with another man
we were just talking we were just
hanging out and then I think he thought
we had a moment and he leaned in and I
was like yo I was like sorry like I'm
not really and then he progressively got
more aggressive and in my head in the
dream I was like I have to fight this
[__] I was like I'm gonna fight
this gorilla off of me yikes dude and
then he stopped and I was surprised if
another man is like hey you want to come
over and chill on my couch I'm just like
no
how did you get him to stop I just kept
shoving it was like he was very
persistent and then in the dream he left
the room and I walked he walked out and
then there was two other guys on the
couch
and then uh oh my God and I was like Hey
where's Jocko and he goes
I don't know where he went and then I
woke up sorry Joe has to go pee God damn
it it's been past 20 minutes
[Music]